here's why I remember about the
nostalgia critic it started off as
something that was just a hobby in my
parents place just to get a few laughs
just to see if I could be entertaining
and from that it just exploded and if
somebody told me when I started that
that was gonna be a huge part of my
identity what I was gonna leave behind I
wouldn't know what to think of it
because it was something I was just
doing for fun what I didn't realize was
that when you start doing this and so
many people do enjoy your work and they
enjoy laughing at it and they feel good
from it that it leaves a bigger impact
than you think it's going to because to
me this is just dumb ass stuff that I do
because it's silly it pays the bills
which is great and I'm one of the
luckiest people in the world to have
that pay the bills but it was nothing
that big or major what really surprised
me was how many people would come up to
me at conventions or on the street and
would tell me that when they're going
through really difficult times when
they're going through just such
harshness that the world throws at them
whether it be losing loved ones or going
through a depression even being suicidal
that just a little bit laughter
constantly in their lives can really
make a big difference even something as
silly as the nostalgia critic that has
meant more to me than any of the success
then you know then people quoting memes
or anything like that but nostalgia
critic to me now represents something
that seems very simple but can make a
big difference to several people out
there but what it's taught me is that
just those few those few kind words
those few bits of laughter that that
little bit of positivity can go a really
long way for people at least for certain
people sometimes it can sometimes the
harshness of the world's just going to
be too harsh but sometimes just that
little bit just that little push can
make all the difference to a person and
knowing that the Nostalgia Critic has
had that impact for some people there's
really no words that can that can
describe what it means to me
and the only way I can tell you what it
means to me is just by saying thank you
to the people who have watched it to the
people that have supported it to the
people that have continued to enjoy what
I put out there and the same way that
just a little bit of laughter just a
little bit of joy or something silly can
make such a big difference to somebody
it works the other way too it works in
the way that just by watching us do our
stuff whether it be me or any of the
other producers it shows your support it
shows that you too want to laugh you
want to feel positive you don't want to
stay in so many harsh ugly places that
the world can throw at you at times you
want to laugh you want to stay positive
and for someone that thought this was
just a silly hobby just something really
goofy and yelling swear words and just
making fun of film something that didn't
matter too much you know compared to all
the other bigger problems of the world
it has ended up meaning the world to me
that through this strange process that
we have helped people that we have made
people laugh that we have helped people
through tough times even if it's through
the silliest way and as I said before
there's no words that can describe how
thankful I am to all the
who watched the Nostalgia Critic who
supported it who continued to watch our
stuff and support what we do it means
the world to me it is the world that
little bit of positivity is just
everything and that's what I remember
about the Nostalgia Critic
by the way don't worry I'm shaving this